hi I'm Sal Khan founder of the Khan
Academy and as you may or may not know
Khan Academy is a not-for-profit which
means I don't own it no one does it is a
public charity and it has a mission of
providing a free world-class education
for anyone anywhere and when we say free
we mean free a free world-class
education for anyone anywhere and so
when you hear that you are probably
asking the next obvious question well
then how does all of this stuff get
produced how does Khan Academy exist and
I would tell you that is a very good
question the way that we're able to do
what we do and I want to make it very
clear it's much more than just me making
videos we now have a whole team of 80
full-time people 80 incredible people
some of the most talented people on the
planet in my mind helping to make
content helping to make software helping
to make tools for parents and teachers
and the way that we're able to do this
is through the generous support from
people like you at whatever level that
you might be able to do it this year
Khan Academy has reached nearly 100
million people and if you look at the
number of people we've been able to
reach for the amount of investment
necessary to do it it's pretty hard to
find something with that much leverage
or that much scale you know back in the
day before I worked on Khan Academy
full-time I was an analyst at an
investment fund and in the investing
world you're always trying to look for
the the maximum return on investment if
I invest $100 here and I get a 30%
return
that's better than investing $100
someplace else and getting a 10% return
but in the in the in the charitable
world and the the not-for-profit world
what we think about is social return on
investment and I think you'll find if
you look at the impact that every dollar
donated to Khan Academy helps us reach
five people around the world five people
who will then have access to a free
world-class education that's a pretty
high social return on investment however
much you value this access that these
five new people are going to have and so
in in this time of giving I'll just ask
that you seriously consider Khan Academy
as a place for making your donation and
not only that
the near-term we have a matching grant
program where one of our generous
supporters has offered to match your
donation dollar for dollar so a donation
of $10 will actually allow us to provide
access to a free world-class education
for one hundred students next year so I
don't think there's any other use of a
$10 that that might make you feel better
inside thank you